BREAK OUT FOR THEHE THE SHOT VEA
STANDINGS FROM
BEHIND WITH McDAVID.
KEEP AN EYE ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
YOUR SCREEN COMING ONTO THE ICE
AND IT HAPPENS A
CHALLENGED BY McDAVID, OILERS
BREAK ON 3-ON-2.
TRYING ICE.
>> T
RYAN IN OFF THE BETTER OF THEMP,
McDAVID LOOKING FOR THE
OPENING.
HEP AT THE
McDAVID ENTERS THE
POSSIBLE.
YOU MENTIOIO AND LOST IT
BEHIND BARRIE. MOORE!
THEN THE EXPLOSION.
MATT TOLDMONTON.
IS Alex: THINGS OFF SIDE.
ARVIDSSON DOESN'T LIKE THEHIGH G
SMITH FROM LONG RANGE.
GETTING IT TO THE OPEN MAN.
SMITHTECHER.
ARVIDSSON ON THE SAVE, REBOUND!
OUT TO HANDLE.THE
>> Jim:E PUCK
TIME FOR THE OILERS WHEN THEY PD
NET
A LITTLE BIT OFF OF
OF THE CORNER, MAKE DURZI, OR
THROUGH?
JUST BY.
DOESN'T ROY.
CHOPPED AWAY FROM HIM.
ADRIAN IS UPSET BECAUSE HE HAD
TIME.
HE CREATED SEPARATION SO EARLY
ON THE SKATE.
OFF THE SIDE OF THE OF THE YEARE
KINGS WITHIN 1!
>> Jim: WAY BACK IN THE OPEN I
TATA
THE OILERS UNABLE TO POSSESS AND
NEUTRALGREAT POKE CHECK BY QUIC.
THRE
POSSIBLE.
>> Alex:
NURSE, THE OPEN NET BROKEN UP BY
KOPITAR.